les chefs d'État de l'OTAN réunis dans
l'Est de l'Europe à Vilnius pour
afficher leur unité face aux voisins
russes avec au coeur des discussions
l'adhésion de l'Ukraine à l'alliance le
président ukrainien invitait au sommet
demande un engagement clair que
l'Ukraine intègre l'OTAN dès la fin de
la guerre avec la Russie
lorsque nous avons demandé à rejoindre
l'OTAN nous avons été francs l'Ukraine
est de facto déjà dans l'alliance nos
armes sont les armes de l'Alliance nos
valeurs sont ceux en quoi croient
l'alliance notre défense constitue un
élément de la formule de l'Europe qui la
rend uni libre et pacifique Vilnus doit
confirmer tout cela
une attente partagée dans les rues de
Kiev
je m'attends à ce qu'il signe au moins
certains documents qui stipulent qu'à
l'avenir nous serons membres de l'OTAN
lundi l'Alliance a annoncé qu'elle
levait certaines obligations à remplir
pour intégrer le temps mais pour aller
plus loin les États membres sont divisés
plusieurs pays dont les États-Unis et
l'Allemagne sont réticents à une
adhésion à court terme pour éviter une
escalade avec la Russie les pays de
l'Est au contraire estiment que
l'Ukraine a prouvé qu'elle avait sa
place dans l'OTAN le temps des promesses
répétées et révolue il est temps de
définir un plan clair sur la manière
dont nous par à l'intégration de
l'Ukraine face à cette fracture le
secrétaire général de l'OTAN insiste sur
la nécessité d'apporter de nouvelles
garanties sécuritaires à l'Ukraine
c'est aux Alliés et à l'Ukraine de
décider quand le moment est venu
d'inviter l'Ukraine à devenir membre à
part entière la tâche la plus urgente à
présent et de faire en sorte que
l'Ukraine prévale en tant que nation
souveraine et indépendante en Europe
pour donner des gages à Kiev plusieurs
états de l'Alliance négocie en parallèle
du sommeil des engagements pour livrer
des armes à l'Ukraine sur le long terme